you probably don't even remember the  first time we met  um I think I was at the Kennedy Center  Honors I was honoring Reba you were  being honored as well because I know  Adam Lambert was honoring you and I I  freaking talked about it for like the  rest of the year I was so excited you're  so cool and sometimes you don't want to  meet your Heroes because you're like  what if they're an ass and you weren't  you were like so cool and anyway has  anybody ever made you Starstruck Meryl  Streep when I first met her  oh Meryl yeah we all did the movie  together yeah it's so good yeah and then  we came we became friends and we've been  friends ever since  oh my gosh what a friendship let's make  that movie um  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]